kobish gun gets gun support those gonna
be I think I'm able to have a very nice
life in Germany now I don't feel any
different at my job because I'm a
foreigner it doesn't make any difference
and I've learned a lot in Germany for
both my life and my work I've learned to
be punctual I can contribute something
new that's positive and makes my life
for my friends and myself a bit richer
it was like him
on our Avena gross says goodbye to
berlin and to her two daughters
the next day she'll be taking off for
Chile Anna wants to see the home she
left behind in 1987 Peter Gallagher
volta East for millionaires I didn't
feel like going back to my home country
Smith now I'm just curious
I'm sure I'll be too excited to sleep
tonight in Houston
we were here here to come understand
severity I love coming here to watch the
city every time I come back to Chile I
have lots of memories when I lived here
I used to come here often with my family
on Sundays I loved living here I never
did plan to leave this country
the capital Santiago is the primary
destination of any visit to Chile ana
spent the greater part of her life in
this city she went to school and to
university here
a new skyscraper is going up that will
tower above all the other buildings in
the downtown area
Ayane meets up with her former
architecture professor Orlando bigger
ooh this stands as a symbol of how
things are in Chile right now the
capitalists have made themselves at home
in this country there's a German Chilean
businessman called pause Palma and his
motto is growth that even more growth
that's what this skyscraper stands for
it's already the tallest in South
America amid the woman but yeah in my
office for a medieval glulam chillin at
the monogamy Oh
I think the Chileans have changed it got
colder and louder I don't know if you've
noticed it yet there no longer is Timmy
and Loki their more demanding and of
course they act like they're not in
South America
or land OVA and Professor Dr unders
Orlando was different from all the other
professors he was more open you could
talk freely with him about anything even
about politics and that was very
important to our safety
get that worth and you remember when you
were living here the army was always out
on the streets at night there was a
curfew Minda mentally teen toil of the
pooch had changed everything from one
day to the next a political project came
to an abrupt end and all at once night
fell now a new day has started they're
still not pleased with the political
climate but that has nothing to do with
what happened back then that was like a
different country
by Afton mentioning September the 11th
Emma Chileans didn't think in New York
City they think of the push against
salvador allende in 1973 what ana now
calls the turning point in her life came
suddenly in february 1987 early one
morning a detachment of secret police
burst into the apartment where she lived
with her then husband they handcuffed
the couple and took them to one of the
most feared places in Santiago at the
time the Borgo no detention center the
police were known to torture their
victims they're the only cause where the
couple's arrest was the fact that a man
wanted for subversive activities had
been hiding in the area
the sisters else the man assist as you
go hope Z is the first time that I've
even seen your eyes capped because I was
transported here blindfolded so I can
only remember sounds as soon as I
arrived I was interrogated at the same
time my husband was being physically
tortured I heard his screams for myself
at first I didn't want to come here or
even think about it he assigned we want
a mixed up and easy yet isn't too tight
for me to Scofield now it's an extremely
strange feeling on the one hand I can
remember very clearly the fear that I
felt then on the other hand now I sense
a great in a calm in war
so d zipper hard the day of my arrest
changed my entire life
it's the reason I left my country at
that time at the age of 22 I never
imagined my life would go this way
about an hour's drive Northwest of
Santiago on the Pacific coast is the
port city of Valparaiso most of the
relatives Ana has left in Chile live
here almost all her immediate family her
parents and her sister emigrated to the
United States in the 1990s so a visit
with her uncle Guillermo and aunt
Cecilia is on the itinerary for her
trips to her home country so is my
family city my parents were born here
and my sister and I were two it's also
the city we have to travel to whenever
something happens in the family whether
it's happy or sad to say Luke Lee but
this time the occasion is a sad one on
his cousin powerless husband died
suddenly a few weeks before he left
behind his wife and three children
the conversation eventually comes around
to the last major earthquake
oh yes a crack here it's not that bad if
the crack had been horizontal it would
have been bad the motion was like this
it was like a wave you couldn't even
walk upright I remember when a piece of
a wall fell on grandma's leg here in
helium via Beeson and yet a moment
contae here here in Chile we know an
earthquake can strike at any moment
of course we consider the worst case
anything can happen you could lose
everything you own but we live with it
nobody complains about it we say I'm
thankful but all the people in my home
are still alive because we know it could
have been much worse
we Mount Zion colonel
for me Valparaiso is the city of my
memories when I walk through the Ellie
ways all the old memories come back to
me straight away playing with my sister
in the streets running around walks with
our parents and I get the feeling that
there are many corners where time has
Stood Still
rather than I can decide a tingly
when police averted a so was the city we
always spent the summer in
signs point to an escape route in case
of a tsunami in northern Chile to
another violent earthquake could occur
at any time
in northern Quijote the Norse didn't
used to belong to Chile in the shoe
Laguna I learned in school that there
was a war against Bolivia and Peru and
Chile won and that's how we came into
possession of the north of the country
and Bolivia no longer has access to the
sea to continue
an hour's drive inland in the middle of
the Atacama Desert on our calls on her
cousin Guillermo
he's a mining engineer at a copper mine
he doesn't have much time for honor just
enough to explain to her the importance
of mineral wealth for Chile I think it
makes up 95% country's overall economic
output you have to bear in mind that
Chile only sells raw materials we don't
export technology or expertise at most
we've got the fisheries industry and the
fruit plantations that's where our
revenues come from Guillermo recommends
a peek into the world's largest open pit
copper mine
the chuquicamata mine
the excavators have eaten their way some
1,000 meters down the Herculean feat
pays off is the price of copper leaps
upward year for year
I can't reconsider slant actually with
all its mineral wealth this country
could be very rich but only a few people
profit from it that's how it's always
been especially
the Atacama Desert is the driest desert
on earth but it's overflowing with
treasures copper lithium gold and
platinum are all here in relative
abundance
here in de vista but the last time I was
out here in the desert was when I was a
young college student even back then
this landscape fascinated me I can find
peace here
sips of ain't even in such a small area
there are the most incredible contrasts
when we drive along the coastline in the
north again and again I see how
beautiful and diverse Chile is
the next plague of Anna's journey takes
her more than a thousand kilometres
south to Copiapo where she meets her old
friend Christian Paris
account first I was surprised that he
had to go to work for the police just
like me and all our friends Christian
was politically active he was part of
the leftist crowd we were always a
demonstration skivvies the one-time
street fighter has gone from masking his
own face to sketching faces of suspects
based on witnesses descriptions his work
goes to help police detectives track
down criminals Christian Paris's boss
joins the conversation he reassures
honor that today's police force has
nothing to do with the one from the time
of the military dictatorship where
ordinary people can come to us and they
can have a look at how working methods
anyone can come everything's open that's
a small but very decisive difference to
the way it used to be the police used to
do everything in secret behind closed
doors serrano secreto
in Okinawa are we working towards
European or North American standards we
want to be the best police force in
Latin American Americana
not too addicted to a snitch meow the
dictatorship no longer exists of course
but I think the old structures still do
that can't be changed so quickly and to
judge by what I hear from people the
anxiety is still there
keep this alpha naught is given from
arts honors no Christian since their
school days he says he took the job with
the police because it was time he
started earning a steady income and
after all he'd studied art he's timber
you met when Christian always has been a
good drawer it's really too bad that he
can't live from his art I think it must
be very hard to find the money and the
time for art in Chile nowadays and
muscley that mehendi used to be more
solidarity today it all comes down to
the market everything has its price
nobody does anything unless they get
something in return it's all about
business now everyone's for himself
everyone's in competition with everybody
else
leave that makan Vidya
my number 2,000 kilometers south
amid thick forests live honors former
in-laws Dogo and Kurata he by day seemed
to pass minutes fight if I mean the two
were almost like a second family to me
they were very important to me at the
time I left the country when I first got
to know them I could say Dogo was a
complete hippie he already had the long
hair and beard he still wears today and
they were trying to live outside of
society to leave he haven't with a young
person but if they sympathized with a
yen day and believed in the dream of
building a new and just society but they
dropped out and now they live in this
magnificent countryside and chef
after the porch Dogo and Carlotta lost
their jobs they fled into the Chilean
wilderness in the late 1980s after the
end of the dictatorship they watched
from a distance as the concertación the
coalition of democratic parties took its
first steps Mucha Namita Chile oh man
this opinion many Chileans hope that the
concept ASEAN would lead to a more left
oriented society one that would really
govern for the people but we've been
disappointed each president has been
worse than the one before
nowhere and a solution Ando Oh
Presidente al otro it was official
they're very hard to get the Social
Development moving again we're observing
the whole process from the outside
because we just can't identify with
what's happening now in this country
didn't the south is very different it
rains a lot here and it's very green I
came down here often as a teenager the
nature is magnificent
back in the capital Santiago in a
drycleaners in a big shopping center Ana
meets a woman she hasn't seen for 25
years she had contacted Sara again
through the internet
anything else - ara is a friend from my
childhood we were neighbours and played
together until I was seven or eight
years old then unfortunately life
separated us and we went our own ways I
went to university and got a degree and
she didn't
there you are and Here I am with the
glasses
there are your popular mama
the dancing look there I am the girl
with the glasses when I was as old as
you are
what was I like you were quiet really
yes because you were the smallest of all
of us I think there was more space here
then wasn't there
yeah we even wrote our bikes here that's
right we rode our bikes here saga is a
divorced mother of three content
illusion it's a constant struggle
constant economic struggle with my
children I want to give them a good
education so they'll be happy and have
good professions they make me happy but
I can't offer them very much in the
material since I mean I can't give them
the very best day look you look is she
done much you know keep your Paris
history kuv Valley what do you really
think of my being abroad of the fact
that I live in Germany it's something I
would have liked to have done someday
travel I think it's fantastic
you found her happiness far away I can
see her happy by the photos you have a
family of your own
they knit the familia mr. food in what
said it was very emotional for me very
surprising very intense we talked a lot
about our childhoods I enjoyed it a lot
it's heavy Sagan Olsen
anna has only a few more hours before
she takes off back to Berlin time for a
few last photos and a walk to La Moneda
the presidential palace
we are Kitty Calvin I don't think I
would have never even spoken to a police
officer before because I would have had
the feeling that no matter what I said
it could be dangerous the feeling that
today I can stand here in front of La
Moneda and talked to a policeman quite
calmly and no longer be afraid is very
important to me and all my fellow
citizens probably the most important of
all
an unplugged Patek this guy at first I
didn't feel like coming back here at all
but for some time now I felt that it's
all right it gets easier and easier for
me to imagine that I might move back
someday after all there will probably
always be a scar it was very painful for
me to leave my country but every trip
back helps to heal it a bit more